i recently was reading
huh sex is very available for you
for everybody
no no that's not that's not that's not
true what no no one one one out of one
out of three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year under
three because they are aiming for
a when if they settled for d no no i
promise you no
statistically women
far easier to have sex find sex and it's
only a small percentage of men who get
the majority of women even even even
women that are very unattractive are
still very picky of course right so
that's what i'm saying if they're picky
they're not picking a large percentage
of men the standard has dropped there
are more women in
situationships
and but with a with a small percentage
of men so like the reason they think
like men are trash is because they're
all screwing the same ones
so so it's like it's like a very small
percentage of men are screwing everybody
fair dudes yeah
on tinder
just sitting in their house waiting to
get tapped into the game so they can be
that guy as well if you look at the
statistics for tinder uh men swipe right
uh is it right for yes
right 60 of the time
whereas women swipe right three percent
of the time yeah so he's like
they're very very selective compared to
men
like think about it how many guys have
moved to you this week
i don't know if i scout
[Laughter]
people can find love
[Laughter]
but i feel like the way guys present
themselves they are not
they they are reflecting a reality that
is not so then because guys like yeah i
get girls yeah it's nothing
that's not that's not true it's only the
guys you pay attention to
that yeah it's only the guys you pay
attention to because generally no one's
trying to you know
you don't notice the guy at nando's
working
i'm sorry
it's disingenuous it's just it's just i
mean you say thank you but you're not
really checking for him thinking does he
get girls you know deep down he doesn't
you know and like women we just know
this stuff and you can you can walk into
a room you as a girl you know who's
getting laid you know who's not good you
don't have to sit they don't have to say
[ __ ] you know he's telling the truth you
know who's not
hanging around with guys
although there are plenty of guys who
don't do this there is a percentage of
guys who massively inflate the idea of
how many girls they're winning
no no okay there is an element yeah
that's that's you're not wrong but like
i i went to like a pickup boot camp once
and it's basically where they teach guys
how to get laid and so i could see i
could see the op the extremes it was
really interesting it was kind of like
like like seeing what they teach the
boys is that in america is that in
america they have them here too yeah um
it's it's a very big case it's like
mustache
no it's a really big community like they
they pay thousands of dollars to fly
into a city yeah and and learn from guys
that know how to get laid how to get
like shocking isn't it
because that's how that's how like
lonely they are but because they they
don't even know what it's like to have a
girl like look at them and be and they
don't even know what it's like to have a
girl excited to talk to them
because we don't we don't if you're that
guy
and you're on eight figures um
the thing is yeah on a real one yeah
it's all laughing and joking but that's
real to them that's their life
and like for you
you look like can laugh and joke because
you don't even understand that life no i
do like no no because you you you you
some degree if you you know what it's
like to get rejected by a small
percentage of guys but you don't know
what it's like to get rejected by
everybody because you know you try no
more yeah you know if you walk outside
like they don't even if you walk outside
and say anyone have sex with me you'll
have takers
yeah but you know i'm saying like those
guys if they said that they would be
looked at like they're crazy and then
probably the police called yeah 100
or sections right and that's and that's
the thing at that boot camp i could see
very extreme ends because you had the
guys that were teaching the boot camp
that get laid all the time and the guys
that were going that that didn't even
that didn't even know how to talk to me
like i couldn't even have a non like
they could barely have a conversation
with me were they nervous
yeah yeah they're awkward i mean some
like oh my gosh i have stories from like
this one guys this one guy was telling
me how he was gonna conquer the world
like he wanted to be like a you know
that's that's a different thing but
there's some
um
but right to this bootcamp yeah and it
was but the the instructors i saw them
take probably five girls home in three
days come on yeah five girls
and so and so each of those girls would
think that she's on the instructor's
level but
i mean they weren't all pretty sorry but
they were there
men and women there to pick up oh yeah
come on you need a you need a you need a
class
to go outside and say does anyone want
to have sex
just do this
you just need to arrive just be there
it's true
does she have a vagina is the
qualification no i mean the girls on my
300 pound life they still got a man
what's up guys
[Laughter]
i have a dungeon
for them okay when they try to keep
escaping i put them in the block dungeon
why don't you why don't you just cut
them off and tell them it's never gonna
happen yeah that's why they're in the
dungeon they when you go over that
boundary of it's not gonna happen and
you still kind of come at me i put you
in prison
which is the dungeon on the block list
of what's up do they concern to this
they don't they're just they're in the
doctor they have no idea you're in
prison now like you don't you so is that
the blocked list yeah but then annually
twice a year i have like parole reviews
and then
i think you're out and then if you
re-offend you go back in for a life
sentence okay can you not see what a
privileged position that is to be
in the sexual marketplace to be in a
position where you're just blocking
people and choosing if you want to go
back to them but the thing is it's
draining it is very draining i haven't
been trying to say since i was 12. it is
i'm i'm tired yeah but one day you
realize one day it's gonna go away and
you're gonna miss it because no one's
checking for girls at 50. my mom is
quite pretty and she's 63. she's
good-looking okay
i've got leeway but i get what you're
saying your sexual market value does
decrease as you get older yeah so it's
like i got one one day you're gonna be
like
i miss the cat
cat calls every year though like i'm
getting old you'll be like where's the
key to that dungeon
can i say something one day you're gonna
be invisible blood fact fact and you're
gonna be like i remember when i was on
that podcast and i was talking a load of
crap rather wait
they're placing that dungeon all right
why why did they end up in the dungeon
why
um some just wanted sex for me i don't
want that so why didn't you just cut
them off completely blocked like this i
did and they kept coming back how how no
i told you some make parole because i
give you a second chance so basically
you're not actually cutting them off i
don't talk to them i unblock them they
don't know they're unblocked it's only
if they maybe
my status i'm just thinking like i don't
want to hold people in my dungeon i want
to release the peace attention is
currency that's where yeah i don't care
about that i don't want them if i want
in them we'll be talking my opinion is
that why aren't we talking to guys that
when you're in such a situation yeah
move out of that situation i do but
sometimes i'm saying
i'm saying that we guys should talk to
other guys
you know if a lady is telling you um no
yes all right later talk to you later
and you move on not even talk too late
just end yeah end is there why why are
you doing that i don't know
i don't want to be on parole i think i
think
so i have a question
you said that sex is too readily
available yes okay so
like what
don't you think like the only way to
make it unreadily available is to get
married young
agreed okay 100 agreed and to
state
your goal because a lot of people are
dating without a difficulty intention
yeah yeah and we were having this
conversation there's no courtship
anymore dating and courtship are too
different courtship means
um marriage is the goal we'd like to get
there let's figure out how to navigate
our way on this journey to reach the end
goal whereas dating is like
the crystal maze yeah you might open and
there might be a trap door you might
fall down a while
is that the man's fault is it a woman's
fault though i think we're both the
sexes are contributing to this issue and
women are on this i'm a feminist sexual
freedom and the truth is
they are
they're not happy they're messing
themselves up but they don't want to
admit that they're not happy because
then to admit that would mean that
actually you've been chatting [ __ ] for
the last 10 years but they're not ready
to let that go
so i think women as well just be honest
you're not enjoying the experience
you're not enjoying the experience
biologically do you know when you have
sex as a woman
something called the limbic system
makes you connect emotionally to a man
that is biological but even if you say
yeah no feelings i'm just lashing and
dashing if he if he hits that wait let
me look at your character he hits that
spot
enough emotions here you will connect
yeah i'll catch him
so basically what you're saying is if
man beats yeah it smashes you properly
yeah continue continually what if it's
just like you know like standard like
it's not nothing so you can still
connect you can still connect
positively
yeah
no you will connect if you keep doing
something over and over again it becomes
habit that's human behavior you will
have to some degree
if wait bearing in mind if she likes
your personality yeah
she will emotionally connect to you yeah
if she likes you even if you've got
whack
pee pee if she can make a cheat man no
no
no she won't cheat because she once
excuse me let me know
let me know
i know why now we can explode and do
whatever
he's probably not the first guy that
she's beat bruh yeah so yeah she
probably beat a man before that was
pretty good yeah she's had to tyrone
before she had eight inches before
tyrone is doing it so like if my man
yeah he's got great personality he makes
you laugh but every time his bedtime oh
boy it's got the shadows here we go
you're giving me from me all it takes is
the next tyrant to call you up
it depends on the girl no it depends on
the girl i know a girl is working with
three inches they got four kids and
she's in she loves him she's accepted
that he's not going to blow the
background she hasn't got the higher
expectations no she's she's she's a
ticking time bomb yeah
that's the that's the thing
it's a girl if a girl if a girl is with
a guy and it's not if she doesn't think
it's the best she can do they usually
leave after they get the kids or what
the resources that they want i'm not
gonna lie the guy takes care of her
they're really good friends they have
excellent communication i think she's
seen that you take care of her bro yeah
what's supposed to do today
similar situation yeah yeah and the girl
hollered me
to blow her back out in front of her
boyfriend and her boyfriend's like yeah
because he can't supply the goods
wow i heard their surgeries wait wait
wait what
well you i told the story before
okay so basically so how did this start
how did you get her number
so i'm at university
last year my first festival in fact i'm
a third-year union i'm like you know
what if i go back to the ends i ain't
going to get a chance to do festival
things i did the festival thing we're
not getting it you know the name yeah
you're from knots yes i went to detonate
see this girl twerking in the middle of
the freaking field i'm thinking what i'm
gonna go catch that wine
yeah
so i'll move everyone out the way i'm
catching that way i'm boom
it's a nice time to you know what the
dance is done so yup i'm sorry so
basically telling me what's going on
right now shows my boyfriend's behind
you
i said what
cool left it there that's the end of
that story
[Laughter]
a few years down the line yeah it's it's
uh no not yet well actually no i'm in
second year it's third year now next
year um
we're having a house party freshers week
i get a text on my phone i open it up i
see a nude it's like eddie wanting to
come over
we ain't spoken you know bearing the
mind i've seen i i've seen the lingerie
this girl's look yeah and i'm drunk i'm
finished it's fresh is weak
so she's like listen i already owed you
an uber it's outside
wow seriously hey yeah so as i'm driving
i'm getting more nudes come through but
what i'm not realizing is that she's not
the one holding the camera
[Music]
so i've i've arrived at this destination
yeah and i've seen a girl come in a big
jacket obviously nothing underneath
and then i walk in i see a guy doing
coke in the corner
i'm not waiting
so oh hello my name's obviously i call
him tony
i'm calling tony
he's a teacher they're both school
teachers the game is all [ __ ] up
so he was just talking now we're getting
to know him as many of you know i was
just banned on tick tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible